robert thibeault est un avocat
montréalais en exil basé à hong kong
depuis trente ans il y est aujourd'hui
persona non grata il fait face à
plusieurs plaintes déposées par le
barreau local tout ça affirme-t-il pour
des raisons politiques
et parce qu'il est l'avocat à d'edward
snowdon le célèbre fugitif qui l'a aidé
à cacher
snowdon est à l'origine de l'une des
plus grandes fuites de données de
l'histoire des etats-unis pour chasser
est accusé par le gouvernement américain
de trahison et d'avoir communiqué
illégalement des informations sur la
défense nationale
l'homme s'est réfugié à hong kong en mai
c'est robert thibault qui lui trouve
alors trois familles d'accueil composé
de quatre adultes et trois enfants qui
vivent dans les quartiers pauvres de
hong kong
objectif les bergers avant son départ
pour la russie ce qu'on appelle les
anges gardiens de snowdon sont en fait
des réfugiés du sri lanka et des
philippines depuis la sortie du film
d'oliver stone en 2016 sur snow donnent
leur histoire a été révélée au grand
jour et a grandement empire et sans
travail ni ressources
ils sont constamment menacés d'expulsion
de hong kong
robert thibault les ati de mise en
danger pour protéger son client il
aurait pu lui dire non dit il
mais ces familles qui ont fui la
persécution ont fait preuve de
compassion watts chinois parmi ces anges
gardiens il y à la philippine vanessa
rodal qui vit avec sa fille née
apatrides snowdon était chez elle
lorsque celui ci a été accusé de
trahison
cachez ce fugitif elle le referait
même si sa vie a basculé depuis c'est un
héros pour moi vivent dans des
conditions pénibles dans les bas fonds
de hong kong
les sept protecteur de snowdon risque
d'être retournés dans leur pays pour
faire face à des représailles les
chances d'acceptation de dossiers de
réfugiés hancock dit robert thibault ne
sont que de deux dixièmes pour cent
autant dire nulles
on n'a pas une vie extraordinaire en
comme quand on est sans papiers
quand nos parents pauvres de travailler
l'organisme montréalais pour les
réfugiés a déposé il ya plus d'un an au
nom des sept pour chasser une demande de
statut de réfugié au canada sur la base
entre autres de persécution personnelle
en tant qu'enjeu gardia d'edouard
snowdon tout est prêt tout est l'un le
comité d'accueil est en place aussi donc
il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
accélérer de pau trancher très
rapidement la décision mais la durée de
traitement des dossiers et de quatre ans
et d'une usine sera-t-il trop tard d'ici
là robert thibault prévient le canada
que ne pas accepter les demandes de
réfugiés de ses sept clients aura des
conséquences fatales pour ceux ci le
temps presse selon lui l'expulsion des
anges gardiens de snowdon pourrait être
imminente
ici frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal